Hello, everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Center. I'm your host as always Ricardo Lob. And
today I'm joined by Dr Nicholas Brown. He's a
researcher at Linnaeus University in Sweden. He works on
developing new research methods in psychology and on applying
meta scientific perspectives on psychology as a. And today
we're going to go through topics like conceptual and
methodological issues in positive psychology and the study of
well being. And then we're going to go through
a few other studies, psychology related studies to talk
about examples of bad science. And then we're also
going to talk a little bit about where bad
science stems from and how we can deal with
it. So, Doctor Brown, welcome to the show. It's
a pleasure to everyone.
Thank you for inviting me. It's always uh always
interesting to talk about what I'm doing.
OK. So let's start here with a positive psychology
and the study of the determinants of well being.
So, uh first of all, tell us a little
bit about how you got interested in this subject
specifically and then we can get into some of
the issues you found there.
Well, until 2009, I was a, I was a
computer guy and I was a manager in an
IT department. And then in what I like to
call a terrible administrative mix up, I got moved
to the HR department. Uh, AND since my, my
bachelor's in computer science had served me well for
the previous 28 years in it, I thought that
maybe I should get some kind of, uh, formal
training in something to do with people, which was,
you know, never II I like to think I
was a good pragmatic manager, but I had no
theory. And um due to a chance encounter uh
with Professor Richard, Professor Richard Wiseman, who was a
sort of fairly well known uh British uh psychologist
Piers in the media. And, and he mentioned, I
I asked him whether there was kind of any
um science that could help with, um particularly when
you work in a large organization, uh your, your
human resources department sends you on training courses to
teach you to be a less bad manager and
things like that. And uh and it seemed to
me this was my, in my new job buying,
buying in those services was part of my responsibility
and it seemed to me that it was all
a bit hand wavy. So I asked Professor Wiseman,
you know, if there's any kind of theory there?
And he said, well, there is this sub sub.
Now he could have mentioned the good old fashioned,
uh, organizational and, uh, and industrial io psychology. Or
he could have mentioned, you know, management schools, schools,
but he mentioned this. He said his new field
called Positive Psychology. They have a Masters at the
University of East London. And it's quite funny because,
like, I think a lot of people I have
a recurring, or I had a recurring nightmare, which
is that it was three weeks until my school
leaving exams. But I had my present knowledge, uh,
of the subject matter. Um, AND so I didn't
imagine in a million years that I'd be going
back to school. But there, I was at the
age of 50 doing this masters in something called
applied positive psychology. And I had this very naive
view of what psychology could teach us about anything.
So, in, in 2011, yeah, I couldn't have named
you three living psychologists. Uh, FOR example, uh, so
I had a, you know, that was a quick,
that was a fast introduction to psychology in general.
I had no, absolutely no background, uh, positive psychology
and, um, as, as part of a, a taught
master's program with a little bit of a research
project tacked onto the end of it. But, um,
that was how I, I got into that. Um,
AND about halfway through it was a two year
masters, the opportunity came up to take early retirement.
So I left paid employment in the end of
June 2012 and decided to see what would turn
up in terms of things to interest me. And
since then I finished the masters, uh I spent
a year in a psychotherapy school where I learned
that I would be AAA pretty poor psychotherapist. And
um then I got a, I got a chance
to be on a phd program uh using some
of the critical stuff that I was writing about
positive psychology and then psychology in general. And more
recently, my work has gone into um bad science
and up to and including fraudulent science and in
psychology and areas beyond. Um BUT the, the kinds
of analyses I do are more suited to uh
social science type uh situations. Although I also do
work on that in things like biomedical, some biomedical
fields. So there's the whole, the whole spectrum of
the science reform movement from doing things a bit
better up to doing less fraud is, is roughly
where I am today. But I, I, yeah, I,
I started off critiquing uh positive psychology both kind
of somewhat theoretically although, you know, I don't have
the psychological background to really, you know, heavily critique
every single construct in terms of the history of
the literature. Um AND, and, and also pragmatically and,
and experimental.
OK. But uh tell us a bit about that.
What were some of the main conceptual and methodological
issues you, you found in positive psychology and the
study of well being?
Well, what I found coming from the outside was
uh and I mean, maybe this is a criticism
of just how psychology works in general. But I,
I know there are people within psychology who talk
about this is what are we measuring? And how
are we saying that things are better or, or,
or, or what is well being? How do you
measure well-being? And it seems to me you can
get psychologists to agree among themselves occasionally that something
is a measure of well-being. But whether or not
that actually relates to what ordinary individuals would talk
about, I don't know. One of the criticisms I
have, for example, is a lot of positive psychology
research uh will say that an intervention made people
happier. And what they will do is they will
count uh an improvement in scores on the BD
I two, the beck depression inventory, which is kind
of the, the gold standard test. But if you
go to a doctor and say, I think I
am depressed, they may give you this. Um So
the BD I is 21 items and each of
them is scored 0 to 3. And the idea
is that uh uh we can say normal, we're
allowed to say no normal person and a healthy
person will typically respond zero to almost all of
them. Because if you actually read the questions, even,
even level one, even a level one answer is
like, wow, that's, that's somebody you might say is
quite often, quite sad, et cetera. Um And a
typical score out of 63 possible on this in
a normal healthy population is about three or four.
So there are about three items out of 21
that a normal person might endorse. Um AND a
a at the first level. And in order to
qualify for a diagnosis of mild depression, you have
to score 14. Um WHICH, and if you read
it, if you read the BD I, and, and
if you yourself have no experience of mental illness
or depression, uh and you think, you know, if
I was endorsing 14 of those, most people, I
think who have no experience of men would go
God, if I was endorsing 14 of those, I'd,
I'd feel pretty bad. You have to get to
14 to be mild depression, then there's moderate and
then there's severe with even higher scores. Now, quite
a lot of positive psychology studies will go out
and, and recruit people. And the whole point of
positive psychology is, it's the psychology of people who
are not depressed and who just want to sort
of do a bit better in life and they
will measure their BD I scores and they'll get
a mean of 4.2 and then they'll do this
whatever psychology, positive psychology intervention and the, the mean
will be 3.8. But I don't know what, what
is the difference between 4.2 and 3.8 when to
even be mildly depressed, you have to be 40.
Why are we measuring at this, you know, ridiculously
low end where, you know, nobody is in any
sense depressed. And we're saying, well, they're, they weren't
depressed before and now they are very slightly more
not depressed. I don't think that that necessarily constitutes
a good measure of whether people are uh experiencing
well-being and something I learned as I went along,
particularly on my master's course. But, but other uh
talking to other people is that a lot of
people who are studying positive psychology are actually quite
depressed, but they are, it seems to me and
this is, this is an opinion and a judgment,
a lot of people who are attracted to positive
psychology are kind of in denial about being depressed
and think that if they could just be a
bit happier, whatever that would mean that they would
be no longer depressed. So then the question is,
is depression the opposite of happiness. And psychologists have
been arguing about that for years, are positive emotions
qualitatively different from negative emotions or are they just
uh you know, plus and minus versions of the
same thing and emotions researchers don't agree about that.
So it, it seemed to me that a lot
of it was um it was ostensibly aimed at
making people who were not depressed happier, but a
lot of the people who want to. Oh, I
really, it would be so much, the world would
be so much better if people were a bit
happier, were really, to some extent talking about either
themselves or their, their depressed friends or, or whatever,
because a lot of people get into psychology, either
to understand their own problems or the problems of
the people immediately around them. Um, AND then the
other side of it was, if it wasn't about
that, the problem was, it was very kind of,
it seemed very suburban and middle class American. Uh,
IT seemed like it was an ideal vehicle for
selling you books for 2499 and improve your well-being
courses for 4 99 99 for 10 episodes. You
know, and you can keep the podcast, you can
keep the MP3 file for a week, that kind
of thing that it, it, it was very, very
easy to be skeptical about it or to be
cynical about it in terms of somebody's making quite
a lot of money out of it. Mhm. And
I kind of have this naive view of science
that science ought to be kind of free. Mm.
Um, II, I, I'm not against capitalism or industry
or anything like that but basic, a scientific finding
should be, uh, you know, if you, if you've
discovered a truth about the universe, I don't think
that's really something you should be able to kind
of patent and license and make money on and,
and, I mean, this is a problem throughout psychology
is that, uh, a lot of the measures, I
don't know, I don't know if the BD I
is one of them, but a lot of the
clinical measures you have to pay, you have to
pay some psychologist 20 bucks to administer this scale
to a patient. And it's like, well, it's, is
it a pharmaceutical thing? Have you manufactured anything? Just,
I, I don't know, uh, who paid for the
research that discovered it? You know, if the NIH
funded it and you discovered it and now you're
selling the result for 20 bucks, how much of
that is going back to the NIH? So, I
don't know, I think there are, I, I just
found that there were all kinds of, of, of
those kind of issues which everybody in psychology seemed
to think was completely normal. So maybe, you know,
maybe I was wrong but I had the impression
that this was, this wasn't how I thought science
was done.
Mhm. And I guess we'll come back to some
of these issues later on. When, toward the end
of our interview, we'll talk about bad science and
what I guess motivates it, et cetera. But uh
I would like to ask you now about a
piece of work that you yourself critiqued coming from.
Uh I hope I'm pronouncing the name correctly. Leu
Bomi at all. I mean, their a happiness pie.
Well, I mean, what is, what were they really
working on? There, what is these or what was
this happiness pay really about? And what would you
say were the issues with it?
Well, the way I read it now is that
in the early days of the Positive Psychology movement,
which was kind of launched with a bang by
a bunch of psychologists saying, you know, we're mad
as hell and we're not gonna take it anymore.
We want people to be happier. We're not just
going to be about, you know, depression. And um
it's, it was kind of a pa it was
a paper that kind of positioned the idea that
people have a substantial amount of control over their
levels of happiness based on what they choose to
do. And so it took a very, it made
it, it, it took what we know about the,
the extent to which your t trait happiness is
genetically determined. Uh And when we say genetically, not
just, you know, genes and your uh uh interaction
with the environment and they sort of said it,
that's about 50%. Now, it's probably a bit higher
than 50% but that wasn't really the big issue.
And then they said, and your life circumstances only
account for about 10% of your happens. Uh And
they added the 50 the 10 got to 60
subtracted that 60% from one and said, therefore, 40%
of your happiness uh is um you know, you
can change, you can make a difference to your
happiness. And this is conceptually not very good. Uh
First of all, these are all population level things.
They don't tell us anything about individuals. But by
far, the biggest problem was it is absurd to
say that people's happiness is only influenced to 10%
of the variance in happiness will be explained by
life circumstances. Uh If you look at um you
know, the, the, the countries that are the happiest
in the world on that one item, how happy
are you survey that comes out every year? Denmark
scores 7.9. Syria scores 2.4. Um It does that
mean. Yeah, so one of them is now, how
should we just say one's one's multiplied by three
to get the other? Let's do that. Let's naively
say that people in Denmark are three times happier
than people in Syria. Um Is that because the
people in Syria are not, you know, listening to
the right kind of music that they really like
or, you know, they, you know, they just need
to kind of get some kind of lifestyle makeover.
Is there maybe something else about living in Syria
about the circumstances of living in Syria uh that
make people less happy? Uh And, and you can
even, you could look at this, for example, with
Greece, where Greece went from scoring like 5.9 I
don't know the numbers off the top of my
head, but basically between 2005, 2014, the whole Greek
financial crisis, the Greek scores went from about 5.9
or something to about 4.2. So Greeks became 40%
less happy. Now, was that because they stopped going
to the gym or did something else happen in
Greece? That? And so it turned out that circumstances
have an enormous effect. And so I went and
dug into what was the source for this claim.
And it turned out to be um some studies
of Americans. First of all, everybody in the survey
was Americans. So the circumstances that they were looking
at could only have been circumstances that are common
to Americans. So there was no, there was nothing
in there about, have you got clean drinking water?
Uh Do you live in a, you know, in
a democracy because everyone had that in common. But
secondly, also if you actually looked what they call
um life circumstances, there were just half a dozen
demographic variables. They didn't in the studies that they
were quoting the what they was not a full
investigation of people's life circumstances. So basically, it was
a hand waving reference to research that didn't show
what they said it showed. And the net result
was, they said only 10% is due to circumstances.
Therefore, the other 40% is available for you as
an individual um to, to alter. In addition, while
the paper itself had one or two hedges about
about this and, and not enough, it certainly didn't
combine the variant in an appropriate way. But nonetheless,
it kind of acknowledged that these, he um Lubomirski
then wrote two books, uh particularly the first one,
which was the How of Happiness, which had a
picture of this happiness pie. So the pie was
the pie chart. 50% gene genetic, 10% circumstances, 40%
you can improve your happiness. Um And you know,
she actually wrote things like that. 40% is yours
to guide. You know, you, you the reader, you,
the individual reader forget the fact that our study
even had it been done correctly, would have been
talking about a decomposition of population level variants in
the popular book which, you know, is signed off
on by Doctor Levski and nobody else, it says
this is yours to guide and that is simply
deceptive, that is simply deceptive because the, the paper
itself, even if the paper were absolutely true. And
I mean, this is another problem we have with
popular science where we, we publish one study and
that then becomes the total truth that we can
build huge narratives around in a, in a what
I call glad well, organization process. But even if
that were the case, that isn't even what the
paper said. Mhm. And, and, and, and so that,
that, that, that, that paper is part of, um
I think we're obliged to think of words that,
that remind you of the phrase military industrial complex.
So, I don't know if we say psychological marketing
comp um complex, but it's part of the uh
the airport book world in which a top scientist
from a top university shows you how you can
hack your life with real science. Tm. And then
when you go and look at the real science.
Tm. Um, IT'S somewhere between, uh misrepresented, wasn't very
good in the first place or outright fraudulent in
a great many of the cases. Mhm.
A and something that you reference there was this
sort of global happiness surveys that we get from
time to time. I mean, how much useful information
do you think we can really get from them
in terms of actually uh trying to understand if
people in a particular country and then comparing across
different countries are really happier or sad. It's
difficult because so this is, we're talking about a
thing called the World Happiness Survey that there are
others. But the, the big one is the World
Happiness survey. And basically it's, it's done once a
year and they go and ask people a one
item question and it's uh on, on a, on
a ladder where zero is the worst life possible.
And 10 is the absolutely ideal life you could
lead. Where are you? So it's actually about life
satisfaction. But life satisfaction versus happiness for the purposes
of this conversation, I think we can treat it
as the same. And what happens is um well,
there are several narratives that get repeated every year.
One of them is that the Scandinavian countries are
happiest in the world and they usually are usually
uh Norway, Denmark, Sweden and Finland will. Uh Finland
is not a Scandinavian country. Please don't write in
listeners um will come out in the top four
of the top five and everyone will say, oh,
these co well, you could argue they're kind of
one country, they're all fairly homogeneous culturally. Again, please
don't write in. But, you know, uh and so
if, if tomorrow Norway, Sweden, Denmark and Finland got
together and said, we are going to form the
Nordic Union, you know, maybe including Iceland and the
Faroe Islands. Um uh We could, they would be
one country and all of a sudden three others
would move into the top 10 cos one of
the problems with the top 10 countries is that
countries are a pretty arbitrary way of defining the
world. You know, you might find that the Marshall
Islands, you know, ev if everyone in the Marshall
Islands, sort of, you know, that if they only
interview 50 people and they all say nine, go,
oh my God. The Marshall Islands are the happiest
country. Let's all rush to the Marshall Islands and
find out what they're doing. You see this with
education uh a few years ago, uh um Sweden
was top of most of the education leagues and
everyone had to go and say, oh, what are
we? We should copy the Swedish model and the
New York Times and all those papers would have
a thing to say. Here's what daily life looks
like in a Swedish school and, you know, compare
that with the US. And then one year Finland
came top. Finland got like half of, half of,
yeah. 0.01 ahead of Sweden. Uh OH my God.
What are the Fins? And it turns out Finland
and Sweden have very different education systems. But now
we all have to sort of say, oh, we,
and we've gone to, you know, various journalists, got
a, you know, uh um flights to Lapland round
about Christmas with their kids, interviewed a few school
teachers. Yeah, there's, and the Finnish model in Swedish
were both completely different, but they were both in
all. So there is this element and any time
you see a top 10 list of countries, it's
immediately meaningless because there's nothing wrong with being the
fifth best country out of 100 and 93 un
member countries. You're probably doing pretty well. Mhm. You're
probably doing pretty well. So one of the narratives
is that Finland is fantastic. Therefore, we should all
embrace social democracy. Capitalism is bad. The US and
the UK are generally about 13th or 14th. But
because we decided to look at the top 10
and Australia's usually in there as well. Australia is,
you know, this is capitalist a country as, as
the US or, or, or the UK. So there,
it, it basically enables people to tell stories. Then
you can say, oh, last year the US was
13th, this year it's 16th. That must be due
to Trump or that must be due to Biden
or that must. Nah, it's just, just, just sampling
error. These countries are all, people are all going
7.97 0.8327 0.841. You know, th this, this doesn't
mean that something radical happened now. Yes, if your
country goes from 6 to 4, like what happened
to Greece, you might go. Hm. There's a problem,
but we didn't need the World Happiness Survey to
tell us that there was a problem in Greece.
So it didn't add anything. We would have been
amazed if it hadn't, if they hadn't got less
happy. If, if, if Greece had had the same
numbers in 2014 as 2005, we would have gone.
They're pretty resilient people. Their country's been completely buffered
about unemployment, went up to whatever it did. You
know, the ATM S weren't working. So that's the,
the, the first problem is if it, if any
change, any small change is likely to be noise
and any big change, you're gonna already know about
anyone. The other problem is it doesn't take into
account the fact that culturally, well, how you answer
a question on the scale of 0 to 10
is going to be quite different. Um, IF I
can be a stereotypical brit for a moment, it's
quite hard. At least the, the view that people
have of the Brits is they're not likely to
say 10. Um, THERE is this, you know, and
again, this, this may be a stereotyping. I am
a brit. So it's not racist but, you know,
this could be a thing. Oh, yeah, they're quite
money. And whereas one might imagine that the American,
yeah. USA number 110, I'm 10. And you can
invent all kinds of stories around that about why
people might say 10 and, and what their culture
has to say about when you're interviewed in the
street by somebody and you don't know them and
et cetera, uh you can imagine that in some
nondemocratic countries that perhaps people are, um, might be
less happy than they say they are. But want
to know, you know, it's like, oh, ok, who's,
who's asking? Oh, you're not from the government. Well,
that's what someone from the government would say. I'm
10. I'm very happy with our comrade leader. So,
you know, all of those things now that you
can kind of compare year on year, I guess.
But as I say, the small changes are gonna
be noise and the big changes you're probably gonna
predict to them anyway. So essentially it's a way
of it provides fodder for filling column inches uh
in newspapers and that may not have been the
intention. And maybe there is some serious social science
that can go on behind that. But by and
large it, it's like university rankings if you, uh
if you sort of, uh even big countries tend,
I don't know whether Portugal does it, but big
countries, you have a thing, like what are the
best universities and what will happen is um they
rank you on about 25 considerations. And so even
if you are the 84th best university overall, on
some measure that we don't know. But let's, you
know, uh, Paul Meal, the great psychologist talked about
someone called omniscient Jones who knew the actual value
of the parameter. Uh, AND, uh, let's say your
university is actually the 84th best out of 100
in the country. It's probably going to be in
the top 10 on one of those measures. And
so you could put, you know, university of wherever
we're in the top 10 on, um, student experience
brackets, outdoor sports or something like that. And if
you aren't in the top 10, you will have
gone, you will have improved 25 places on one
of these measures and you go, the results are
out, we improve 25 places on student experience, indoor
sports. Congratulations. Every, everybody and, you know, all have
won and all must have prizes. But guess what?
People are still applying to Oxford and Cambridge. Yeah.
No, you know, that this is also funny because
uh uh it came to mind that uh also
sort of loosely related to this happiness surveys. Then
of course, you can also market and sell those
books where people find uh culture, uh uh some
sort of culturally contained, let's say a concepts surrounding
the lifestyle and happiness. Like for example, in Japan,
the Iki guy and in Denmark hike or, or
h or however you pronounce it and, and then,
oh my God, you just have to do this
and you will be happy
forever. And then, and so you spend two years
buying all the ike guy stuff and then that
doesn't work. So then you go and buy all
the hugger shit and then you buy whatever the
Swedish stuff is and you've got this house full
of crap. Um Yeah, I mean, the point is
that a lot of people have outsourced their thinking
about their happiness to experts and while that's a
sensible thing to do on things like, um you
know, cancer and blood pressure, um I, I would
argue personally and II, I never thought about this
until I got into psychology. But I mean, why
do we even, why do we have psychiatrists? Why,
you know, why do we have psychiatrists for many
conditions that are really just about being human? You
know, obviously, if you have some kind of neurological
disorder, uh if, and, and you know, I'm sure
things like schizophrenia and things like that have some
kind of biological basis. But uh we've, we started
off with that and then we kind of ended
up medicalising everything and, and it, which is ironic,
cos um positive psychology likes to think that it's
not about the medicalization of everything. But uh though
II I um bit of a plug, but it
won't sell many copies. I edited a book on
which we call critical positive psychology. And there was
an excellent chapter in there saying, well, positive psychology
claims to reject the medical model, but look what
they're doing. And in fact, you know, part of
the medical model is I am an expert. You're
not. If you give me some money, I will
treat you. And again, I don't have a problem
with that with the person who, you know, fixes
my cardiac arrhythmia. But uh so I think a
lot of people imagine that they must, they don't,
they know that they don't know very much, you
know, nobody knows very much about it. Even the
kind of philosophers of happiness over the years acknowledged
they didn't really know much about it. But we
imagine that there must be experts that we can,
if we can just give them some money, then
they will fix that problem in the same way
that they fixed our ingrowing toenail. And um so
there is this huge market for that and, and
it, it's interesting when Positive psychology was launched, it
was very much um it was with an attack
on the people at the, the softer end of
psychology, the, the humanistic psychologists because, and it blamed
them for the fact that the all the self
help books are about, you know, the secret and
your inner child and, you know, assorted bullshit. Uh
And, but there was an element of jealousy there
in that, uh those books sell and make a
lot of money and, and most of the leading
positive psychologists have one or two New York Times
best selling books based on their research and the
research of their fellow uh positive psychologists. And the
research isn't always all that great. And then at
that point, how much of a difference is there?
Um PARTICULARLY because, and I think this is a
studying also in, in, in psycho a wider psychology.
There's a certain kind of psychologist that you meet.
When you go to a psychology faculty, there are
the ones who are absolutely interested in, in measuring
this and cognitive performance and, and, and the determinants
of depression. And then there are others who've basically
got a theory that they want the world to
listen to and they're in order for the world
to listen to them. OK, I've gotta go and
dig up some data, but they're, they're not kind
of going into the lab every morning in full
Richard Feynman mode trying to, trying to disprove their
theory. Um These people tend to be quite charismatic,
they tend to do good presentations. Um, AND they're
clearly on some kind of mission, excuse me. And
now if sometimes that gets attacked as, you know,
some sort of lefty socialist mission or occasionally, you
know, even some right wing mission on intelligence and
things like that. But in general, it's not really
a political thing. It's much more a sort of
be in their bonnet that they're right, they know
that this is, you know, a solution and often
they've come to that out of a very sincere
desire to confront either their own issues or issues
in their family. Um You know, I want to
know, I um people who research suicide, for example,
a lot of people who research suicide have a,
you know, sibling or parent who, who kill themselves
and it's very difficult, it's incredibly difficult to critique
suicide research. You know, a lot of suicide research
is terrible but you can't, it's very hard to
go to suicide research and say stop doing this
and be well, why do you not care about
suicide? Really, really hard. So, yeah, there is, it
seems to me there are a lot of, of,
of psychologists whose they're more about the communication about
the ideas than they are about the scientific side
of it that, you know, treating it as if
it was uh a biomedical science where you collect
data and do the analysis and draw the graphs
and say, look, this is, this is really happening.
Um, AND I, I don't know, I, if people
are watching this, who work in psychology departments, they
may be nodding along going. Yeah, I have colleagues
who, for whom the research is kind of secondary,
not in any sort of fraudulent way, but they
are, they're kind of special people, not in a
science nerd, kind of a way. Um, YOU know,
they may be very spiritual individuals, et cetera and
that's great, but it's quite difficult to be very
spiritual, to be a really, really, really good psychologist.
You have to be extremely good at maths and
extremely good with people. That's, that's a rare combination
of skills.
Uh So I I mean, it seems that there's
also this sort of element of uh potentially getting
some social and moral backlash if you're trying to
critique some of these research, you mentioned suicide research
there, for example, I mean, so some of these
research when it comes to particularly very sensitive social
topics is sort of v from criticism.
Well, also because the majority of people who research,
let's say a politically sensitive topic typically start out
from a political point of view on that. So
the majority of people who research police racism start
off, I think from the point of view that
there is a lot of police racism. Um THE
majority of people who look for race differences in
IQ probably start off from the idea that certain
groups are less intelligent than others um, and most
people, yeah, you're not going to go into that
topic unless you're somewhat motivated to do it. And
so if it is a political topic, you're probably
going to have an, a priori political position. Now,
maybe there are people who go along and have
epiphanies, uh, along the way. But it's very difficult
when you come to, um, an entrenched, when you
come with a, you know, an entrenched a priori
political position. It's very difficult to, to accept, um,
contrary, uh, empirical evidence. Um Michael Shermer had a
book called Why People Believe weird things. And one
of the things he said is, uh, people believe
or smart people. They, well, one of the chapters
is why the smart people believe weird things. And
he said, well, the thing is smart people are
very good at unders justifying why they believe the
weird things in the first place. But they've still
got to get the weird things kind of out
of it. If you look at smart people who
are very religious and, and who are religious in
the religion of their parents, you know, we all,
you know, we're pretty, we all know that the
chance that the religion of our parents is the
right one. You know, certainly any sort of, you
know, anyone with a logical and scientific brain should
realize that any, that the chance that the religion
that your parents happen to inculcate in you is
the right one. It's fairly small. Um And then,
but you see, you know, orthodox Jewish, orthodox Jewish
particle physicists who are kind of discussing the, you
know, the finest points of detail in the world.
But they uh uh I, I saw one such
person being interviewed but she wasn't mixing pans with
like milk and meat or something and, and, you
know, ditto for any other religion. Certainly not to
um say anything about the uh uh Jewishness. But
if you're going to be have that, if you're
going to say, as I, as a scientist, I
am, you know, objective about the, you know, oh,
and by the way, I have this corner with
religion, which I mean, maybe they try to defend
with the religion objectively. But I think most people
who are religious will say, ok, that's outside the,
that's outside that box. Um You're already kind of,
to some extent justifying why you're, you know, you're
not looking at that. I, I'm not certain if
I'm making quite good sense here. But, um, people
are, yeah, people justify themselves into that position and,
um, it's hard to get out of it and
it will take a lot more, um, it'll take
a lot more co contradictory evidence before you start
believing the opposite of your initial hypothesis, particularly if
it was the entire basis of you going into
that field in the first place. Uh Very few
people make that transition. I'm thinking of um Hilda
Bastian, a science writer. And she started off as
I think she may have been anti vaccine, she
was anti something. Um IT may have been anti
vaccine, anti some kind of medical procedure. Uh AND
she went and read the evidence and she realized
that the evidence was actually true. And now she
writes about um deniers, well, first of all about
bad scientists, which is great, but also from the
point of view of someone who's, you know, started
off believing a lot of bad science. Um And
she's an absolute beacon from that point of view
because she actually did the, she crossed the line,
she crossed the line and will, I'm sure would
tell you, interview her, do interview her Hilda Basket.
She'd be a fantastic interview. She would tell you.
Uh Yeah, you know, I used to believe this
and here's why and most of us who've been,
most of us have been lifelong. Most scientists have
been lifelong scientists. We haven't had to undergo that
conversion. We can't tell you what it was like
the day when we realized that Chem Trails couldn't
be real. Um So people who've been through that
journey, I think uh uh but they are, they
are few and far between and, and even more.
So when you've made a public position and when
you're, you've got a book deal, you know, you,
you've got a book deal, you've maybe you might
have written two or three or four popular Bestselling
books on YX is the way to lose weight,
become happy all of that. And even if just
in those moments before the, before you fall asleep,
you have a little bit of a doubt, you're
probably not gonna co um phone your publisher and
say Pulp the lot. I just realized it's garbage.
Yeah. So uh uh still on the topic of
well being, I would also like to hear a
little bit about your critique of another study in
this case by Frederickson at all, uh uh uh
work on the relationship between genomics and well-being because
at a certain point there, you also mentioned that,
I mean, there could be, or there might be
some sort of genetic basis to this to some
extent. But in the, in the, in the case
of that particular study, what would you find as
the main a conceptual and statistical?
Yeah, this was, this was quite the, this was
quite the uh quite the study. Um Frederickson presented
it at a conference with a um a picture
of a couple of the charts, one of them
going one way and one of them going the
other way for the, the two conditions. Uh And
the uh the title of the slide was an
objective basis for moral philosophy question mark which um
there, there were two main problems uh with this
study and I presume you'll put the reference in
the notes. Um The first was that it was
it was about the sixth or seventh study that
the s last author had produced, using a way
of analyzing uh data which is completely invalid. He
basically made up his own statistical method and this
method is going to lead to large numbers of
false positives. Uh And I, I've cried, I predicted
another paper where someone had done something similar and
they, and they replied, but we replicated it. It's
like, yes, because your, your method reliably produces large
numbers of false positives. Um So that was the,
the first problem is the method was nonsense. Um
An even bigger problem, however, was that when they
were coding up the data, uh they decided that
they, they collected data on people with this rather
strange American way of collecting race. So uh Amer
the the US US scientists used the census definition
of race from about 1910. And in the 1910
US census, there was black, white, uh native American
Asian, which kind of meant Japanese immigrant, uh Hawaiian
and Pacific Islander. Now, clearly those are not, you
know, in any way representative of, of, of, of
the human population. But OK, there was Hawaii and
there was Guam. So we kind of had to
include them. There isn't, for example, a code for
Hispanic and Hispanic is orthogonal to race and you
can be black Hispanic or white Hispanic. So uh
and nobody dares touch these now because obviously to
try and re you know, reconstruct that would be
just a political nightmare. Anyway, they collected these data
and either they didn't get a significant result, but
for whatever reason, they decided to recode them as
white and not white. So instead of white being
one and all the others being 23456, they just
had uh white is one and everything else is
zero. And they must have done this by hand
because they left a four in. So they had
all these ones, all these zeros and a four.
And they then used that without noticing as a
binary variable in a regression. And basically, if they
held all ones and zeros, it wouldn't have mattered
if they'd been ones and zeros or fours and
twos. But as soon as you have three values
for what should be a binary variable in your
aggression, they actually start behaving like real numbers. So
we discovered this and we found that. So again,
let's pretend that the method isn't full of statistical
artifacts. Let's pretend that the method is correct. Even
with that method. When you corrected this incorrectly coded
person, the main effect of the study reversed. Hm.
Did it reverse or did it halve or both?
Anyway, it was drastically altered simply by changing that
one data plot. So we wrote this up in
our rebuttal. And what happened was the authors. So
we said to people, but if you download this
file from this gene database and you run their
code. This is what will happen and look, here's
that form. The authors took that data file, corrected
the four and re uploaded it. They didn't tell
anyone, they didn't put a note on it. They
didn't tell us and they didn't tell the journal.
So now anyone who downloads it will go. Well,
what's this brown sl what are they talking about?
The results are? Um So yeah, a combination of
the method was completely wrong and there were errors
in the data. Um And so the whole thing
was just nonsense, just complete nonsense. Uh But you
know, it took quite, it took, it took many,
many hours and days of dredging through. You know,
the data file is like 35 megabytes or something.
It's complete genomic analysis and then all these variables
that go along with it. So, yeah, the method
was wrong and they hadn't even implemented the method
correctly. Uh We wrote to the editors and said,
we really think you ought to retract this paper.
It's based on, you know, we can argue about
whether the method. Yeah, it, it is full of
artifacts. Here are several statisticians who will tell you
it is. But OK, that's a scientific argument. But
the data had this error in it and when
you correct it, the, the effect goes away. Um
And the authors tried to sneak a new version
of the data past you and the um the
editor refused to uh to consider it. So when
he got fired a couple of years later for
some me too stuff, uh, I, we were, I
was quite pleased. But, um, yeah, so that's, and,
and that was an interesting example but an entirely
typical example of how science doesn't get corrected because
in the same way that if you've got a
theory and you're committed to it, it's embarrassing to
come back for it. It's very embarrassing for a
journal edit to, to admit that they published a,
a garbage paper, uh, with, with data errors in
it that, that completely trashed the results. So they
just pretend it didn't happen and hope no one
will notice.
Mhm. But, but when it comes to the statistical
analysis that were applied in this particular study, since
we're talking about genetics here, do you find that
perhaps some of the issues would also extend to
other genetics research or
you'd have to talk to a genetics researcher? Um,
I do know that, um, about 15 years ago
there were problems because people were attempting to identify
which gene was responsible for this or that phenomenon,
uh, by basically, uh testing 35,000 genes, uh, and
seeing which of them were associated with an outcome
without making the necessary statistical corrections. And so they
were generating huge amounts of, um, of, of false,
false positives. But you'd have to talk to somebody
who knows a lot more than me about genetic
research. I, I had to do quite a lot
of learning in, in quite a hurry for that
paper and I've forgotten most of it now.
OK. So let's move on from uh happiness and
well being here because I, I would also like
to get into another paper, this one from 2015
by Thorstenson Pastor and Elliot. Where, I mean, uh
th this is very interesting and funny in a
way, I guess they sort of offered evidence from
two experiments that perception of colors and in this
case, it was on the blue, yellow axis was
impaired if the participants have watched the sad movie
clip. Compared
to part, if you're feeling blue, you can't see
blue or something.
Yeah. And this was compared to participants who watched
clips designed to induce a happy or neutral mood.
So, what were the main issues, methodologically speaking here?
Um I, I, I've always been surprised that that,
well, I mean, I presume this, I think this
is done with undergraduates. I've always been surprised that
um undergraduates who have been watching four hours of
TV, since per day, since they were four years
old. Um So they've probably watched 20,000 hours of
television. And apparently psychologists believe that if you show
them a mildly sad or a mildly funny clip
for about six minutes that they will all of
a sudden be in some kind of, you know,
happy or sad mood. But apparently we have to
stipulate that we have to accept that um the
bigger problem in this study is that the uh
the results were fabricated. So uh there's not really
a lot of point in going any further. Um
The editor of the adjourn at the time is
a terrifically nice chap. And he didn't want to
get into too much of a confrontation with the
authors. So um a suitable fig leaf was arranged
in terms of the reason for the retraction, but
it's, it was abundantly obvious if you looked at
the data set that these numbers had been fabricated.
Um So obviously, you can get any result you
like if you just make them, make, make, make
them, make the numbers up. Um So yeah, that
was, that was nice and simple. That was a,
that was probably the first case I worked on
where I actually had data in front of me.
And I go, yeah, this is obvious fraudulent.
Yeah. Uh And so uh from the same year
actually, and we're talking about this sort of thing
nowadays, I guess with Twitter and other kinds of
social media. So there was also this study on
how supposedly through Twitter language, uh the authors could
reliably predict heart disease. And this was um I
mean the name here is a bit complicated. I
stabbed by it all. Yeah. So what, what are
the criticisms here? And by the way, do you
think that they would extend since I'm mentioning uh
the uh the fact that we still talk a
lot about how much reliable information we can get
from uh, patterns of language and other sorts of
activity on social media. Uh, AB about this or
that kind of issue that we can. So, do
you think that these would apply to other research
using Twitter or other social media? They, no, I
mean,
everything's far too noisy. They were just, they, they,
they ran enough models so that eventually they managed
to model some noise down to a P value
of 0.049. Um And if you get 0.05 someone
will publish it. Uh And uh they, it, yeah,
they, there were all sorts of things wrong with
that paper at one point. They were, they were
using some reference data. Uh BUT it turned out
that was from Facebook, not from Twitter. And, you
know, Facebook and Twitter populations are different. Um They
showed a map of, you know, this area is
close, it looks like that area and it, it
wasn't, there were hundreds of differences but it was
kind of visually impressive. Um And, you know, basically,
uh uh what I was saying earlier, there are
someone, the uh the couple of the people on
that paper have this idea that you can with
machine learning or with big, big linear models d
discern trends in extremely noisy data. And the answer
is you can't, and you know, they, they didn't
realize that their data had been censored somewhat by
Twitter. So they thought they were getting pure data.
Uh, Twitter had taken out a lot of stuff.
So this was about the claim of the study
was not that angry people get heart disease. The
claim of the study was that US counties where
there was more anger expressed on Twitter had higher
rates of heart disease, which would typically be among
non Twitter users. The data were from like 2011
and 2012 when there weren't that many people on
Twitter and the kind of people uh who get,
uh who get uh atherosclerotic heart disease uh tend
not to be on Twitter anyway. But you had
this idea of an, you know, an angry county
full of, I don't know, rednecks, whatever. Uh And
it turned out, yeah, Twitter was censoring the data.
So there was all kinds of anger related stuff
uh in the data that wasn't in, that wasn't
in, wasn't there that wasn't given to them because
Twitter bowdlerized uh the data, they took some of
the rude words out. Um Then I showed that
if you, um if you, instead of looking for
anger, you looked for upbeat things, but that also
predicted, I can't remember if I said it predicted
heart disease or if it predicted cancer. But basically,
if you've got enough variables, you know, that if,
if anger is predicting that particular form of heart
disease, well, how many other forms of disease did
they look at and which ones did they choose
to publish? Uh So it was, it was just
a, it was just flashy nonsense. It was flashy
nonsense but it didn't prove anything at all. Uh
But the reviewers of that paper could not possibly
have understood it. I mean, I, I have a
degree in computer science and it took me 2.5
days to download all the stuff that I needed
to get the model to run. Uh NN none
of the reviewers ran any of those models to
replicate them. So they would have just gone. Oh,
there's this big complex computer model. Well, it must
be right. Well, you know, the model, the model
could be wrong and I have no way of
knowing that, but a big complex software model. Uh
I mean, this is a, this is a uh
a more general problem for science is that a
lot of the time, even if you trust that
the people collected the data, you're also trusting that
their 12,000 lines of code doesn't have any bugs
in it. Well, you know, your, your, your viewers
who know a bit about software, maybe uh having
a bit of a smile at that. Um And
so, you know, we ran this model and look
these numbers came out. Can we have a publication
now, please? Just, you know, and, and as I
say, we, I demonstrate, for example, one of the
things was if you cut the new outage states
in half, the effect was only present in the
north of the United, in the south of the
United States and not the north or vice versa.
Well, there's no theoretical reason why angry people in
your county, north of, of Missouri uh would, would
cause you to have more heart disease in that
county and not in the south. And then I
found two counties in Indiana that were like next
to each other and one of them was 10
times more angry but had half the heart disease.
So there's no, there's no useful, the, the, the
the biggest problem with that article was, it was
like claiming that somehow health authorities were going to
be able to, you know, oh, let's not, you
know, what's the best predictor of this year's mortality
from heart disease? And the answer is last year's
mortality from heart disease, um especially since uh the
determination of mortality from heart disease is what's written
on the death certificate. And it turns out there
are enormous differences in medical diagnosing practice based on
local cultural factors sometimes including whether one particular doctor
had a big influence. You know, if you're in
a uh an area with a big city hospital
and, you know, oh, for the last 50 years
ever since professor. So and so we, we try
not to say that it's atherosclerotic heart disease because
we look for these other more subtle factors or
vice versa. And So it's all of these extremely
noisy measures being thrown into a regression. Eventually something's
going to kind of pop out one side or
the other. Um, AND it, you know, but it,
it's not useful. Uh But it makes, again, it
makes, it's a press friendly story. The press likes
to say, oh, wow, pretty soon we'll be able
to see whether, you know, you're, you're likely to
get heart disease based on what, what's, what's being
tweeted in your neighborhood. Oh, wow. Gee whiz. Um
YOU know, sorry, predicting heart disease was going to
continue to be um difficult. But the best basis
we have for it is, you know, what happened
last year and how much pizza you eat. So
and a lot of this is about cute, so
cute stuff gets published. The thing about, oh Feeling
Blue makes you see blue or rather not or
something. Uh And all of these articles get coverage
in Huffington Post and even in, you know, the
Daily Mail and even in the Times sometimes, um
because we've got to generate content and so psychologists
to some extent can also, or scientists and university
press offices. Uh Although my colleague, Chris Chambers had
a look at that and determined that the scientists
aren't always completely. Oh, yes. The press office made
me do it. No, no. But the press offices
are producing these, you know, stories uh and feeding
them to their friendly journalists and scientists at the
university of whatever. And then they can go, hey,
University of wherever is in the news again with
our world leading research. So it's all part of
that kind of mutually reinforcing, um, world of, um,
en entertainment, water cooler discussion. Clicks. It just feeds
that and, but it's all nonsense. Almost all nonsense.
So we can't tell what is it?
Ok. So, uh, le let's get a little bit
more into what might be behind the bad science
here. I mean, we could have gone through some
more studies that you yourself debunked or found flaws
with. But let's get into some more general questions
and issues here. So when it comes to perhaps
having a better understanding of where bad science stems
from and the factors and do you think that
uh it is better to try to approach it
at an individual level? I mean, is it mostly
about people, individuals with certain personality or psychological traits
uh having a tendency to particularly produce fraudulent data
and studies or is it more a systemic issue?
And if it's a systemic issue, then we might
get into some of the main factors here.
I mean, I think mostly it's an, it's an
interaction of the two but the, the, the system,
as it itself, the system itself, the scientific production
system um you know, exists in an economic context
and you know, the economists, uh most of them
who aren't making their data up, but economists can
tell you if you, if you show an economist
from Mars, uh, if you describe the system in
which scientific research takes place, uh, they will tell
you exactly what's going to happen, which is that
people are gonna respond to incentives. Um, AND we,
we have this idea of the scientists as the
kind of 19th century gentleman Sikh, uh, with, you
know, independently wealthy and, and dabbling in things to,
you know, to plant species or, you know, the
odd uh still, you know, seeing if you can
get chlorine gas out of it or whatever, um
uh very much all the sort of, you know,
the noble, the noble cause of, of advancing human
knowledge. Um But first and foremost, scientists are employees,
they are working in an economic system, they need
to go home at the end of the day
and put food on the table. Um They worry
about their career, they worry about uh their visas.
If they're from another country, they also have normal
human drives and desires such as prestige, um you
know, bettering themselves, making a lot of money in
some cases and the way science is set up
makes it relatively easy if you are prepared to
be a bad actor to do that. Now, I
don't know whether there are, you know, more sociopaths
or more generally bad people in science than any
other uh domain, you know, like banking or uh
you, you quite often read out someone the other
day on Twitter. I, I had some sympathy with
them and they, they were trying to sort of
fill in their expenses from their university and they
had to jump through hoops to get $30 reimbursed.
And they said, you know, it always seems to
be the university administrators themselves who've been creaming tens
of thousands of dollars a year off the top
when the scandals come to light. You know, it
isn't, it isn't the, the research who goes to
two conferences a year over claiming $40 on a
taxi ride, that's going to be what, uh, what
breaks the budget. So, but, um, people, people of
all kinds and all classes and all backgrounds are
exposed to temptations to cheat whether that's professionally financially,
uh, et cetera. And we shouldn't expect scientists to
be any different. I sort of give this analogy
of, uh, when your university, when it comes to
the end of the month or the fortnight in
the US when it comes to the end of
the month, uh, you get a payslip, uh, saying,
you know, your gross pay your net pay after
tax. And they say, and we've sent this money
to your bank account. What they don't do is
say, ok, your net pay after tax is 3.5
1000 just go along to room 47 and take
35 100 bills off the top of the pile.
They don't know why don't they trust you. Uh
And yet we allow scientists essentially without any external
supervision, certainly without any external supervision, you know, of
the kind that could say stop, you can't do
that uh to um mark their own homework, decide
themselves what numbers they're going to present. Um And
one number will get you a book deal and
the other number won't. Um YOU know, that's quite
a temptation. You have to be more than averagely
honest to turn down the prospect of a quarter
million dollar book deal based on publishing or not
publishing a result. Um So yeah, we expo we,
we at the top, I mean, not, not very,
not many scientists do this, but at the top,
the rewards are very high and therefore the temptations
are, are are there. But even in the middling
level, um we see this particularly in China where,
you know, you've gotta have this amount of publications
to continue, but it happens in the West too.
It just seems to be more of a uh
and, and so people will pay somebody to write
a paper for and then they can say, yes,
I published this paper and no one's ever gonna
come along and say so tell, no one's gonna
give them a, a spontaneous Viber, no one's gonna
say so tell me about this. So this variable
moderates this and they're gonna sit there, they didn't
write it, they didn't understand it. Um So yeah,
I say in, in, in particularly China. It's got
to the point where large numbers of people are
just having papers written for them. Uh, BUT all
over the world you've got all of these do,
um phd candidates and post docs desperate to keep
their job, keep their visa, et cetera and who
will do what it takes. And particularly if they're,
uh, you know, the, the boss of their lab
who is pretty much God, you know, there's no
other sort of appeal, um, tells you to come
up with, you know, data that show the right
num the right results. Well, you're gonna give them
that data or you have to leave or you
have to leave and a lot of people do
leave, they walk away from science, uh, because they're
too disgusted about what they were being asked to
do, but most of them don't blow the whistle
on the way out because the bar for doing
so is very high. The evidentiary bar for proving
that somebody committed fraud is very high. And now,
as we've seen in, in, in a recent case,
we've even got somebody credibly accused of fraud and,
and then, um, claiming that it's malicious libel, you
know, to point out that none of these numbers
add up. So, um, it's, it, it, you're very
unlikely to get caught, uh committing scientific misconduct. And
historically, you've certainly been very unlikely to get caught.
And so if you're in a situation where you
have a choice between two options. A and B.
Uh One of them will either make you rich
or at least ensure your continuing employment and visa
and the other won't. Um, AND no one will
ever find out that you cheated to get to
this result. Um It doesn't surprise me that a
lot of people do. That doesn't surprise me at
all. I think we would be, it would be
really weird if, if we discovered that no scientist
ever did cheat, we would want to sort of
bottle whatever it is. They've got cos we could
use that with every other aspect of human endeavor,
you know, politicians, et cetera. Um But, you know,
it, it's just not the case, it's just not
the case, but science is set up and, and
the popular view of scientists is these rather aloof
individuals but who we can trust. Trust me. It's
the science, it's not me saying it, it's the
science that's saying it. I am merely the, the
kind of priest through whom the science is channeled
to you. Uh So you have to believe it
and yeah, all sorts of things can go wrong
there as we know from every, every other aspect
of our society in, in, in almost any other
aspect of our society. If people came along and
said, you know, trust me, this, this, this would
be go yeah. Right. You know.
Yeah. A and we also have to get a
little bit more into that uh idea of trusting
the experts because uh I, I mean, knowing what
we know about how sometimes we should be careful
about trusting some published science. I mean, perhaps we
have to talk a little bit about how we
really should communicate that idea to the general public.
But uh before that, let me just ask you
a little bit more about the publishing system in
science. Do you think that uh there might be
some issues with it that also play a role
in how and why? Apparently there are so many
bad studies slash papers uh published.
Yes, I mean, it, the system is clearly nuts.
In the, in the late in the early 21st
century, you would never organize the system around that.
What we have is the result of 300 years,
but certainly 50 or 60 years of repeated kind
of um optimization of a process that suits the
publishers and doesn't and suits suits the individual scientists.
It just doesn't suit the interests of science. And
there is um there is a sort of growing
realization that the people who are successful are successful
cos they published a lot and therefore they're not
gonna call into question the publishing system. It did
OK, by them, uh the people who are criticizing
it are the people who haven't yet published a
lot. And of course, the people at the top
would say, well, you're just jealous, you just haven't
published a lot once you understand the system, you
know, you'll see that it's good for you. And
of course, the people who are selected to be
at the top are the people who published a
lot. So it's self reinforcing. I mean, it, it
actually means you can't tell one way or the
other, both sides are biased, both sides are biased
or have the potential to be biased. I personally
back the people who say that the system is,
is wrong, but we should acknowledge that the people
who are saying the system is wrong are by
and large, not the people who've been through the
system. And that, that doesn't prove that the people
who are saying that it's good because they've got
to the top um uh our, our role, but
we should, you know, consider that possibility that they're
there because they were successful at publishing. So, um
you would need to have a kind of relatively
neutral external party to say, you know, is it
a question of survivorship bias or is there something
something deeply wrong with the system? I, I think
it's fairly easy to make out the case that
there's something fairly wrong with the system. Uh But
um it's, it's, it's what we all grew up
with and there's nobody, you know, there's nobody who
remembers the time before it was about journals and
impact factors and um you know, other stuff that
you shouldn't be doing. So the publishing system, we,
we've we've, the, the sort of administrative side of
academia has piggybacked onto completely contingent features of the
public trading system such as uh uh H index
and citation counts. Um WHICH somebody came up with
one day, you know, in someone in 1963 wrote
a paper saying, how about we count someone's H
index? And all of a sudden the H index
is all that counts as a measure of your
uh academic productivity. But we didn't, we didn't have
a commission, we didn't have a sort of 15
year scientific commission to say what's the best way
to evaluate uh research because we were in a
hurry and we needed stuff doing now and this
was handy and we'll do that and now everyone's
and, and same with um impact factor journal, impact
Factor. And so journals now spend a great deal
of their time trying to manipulate their impact factor.
Uh So for example, what's very common and some
publishers do it more than others, but it's common
is that an article will be published uh online
first and then it won't appear in the paper
if there is a paper, but it won't get
proper page numbers and a volume number uh for
18 months. And the reason for that is that
the impact factor is measured for the five years
after official publication. So they want to hit the
ground running. And of course, it's very difficult for
a paper to get cited in the first. Um
No, I just, if Zoom has just seen me
put my hand up, yeah,
I, I, that, that's C I for you, I
guess.
Um BUT yeah, so um what was I saying?
Yeah, so um obviously when your paper appears it's
not gonna be cited the next month because anything
that might cite it has to be written and
has to go through the pipeline. And so a
lot of journals now, for example, are, yeah, not
publishing, not putting an official publication date and page
number on an article for 18 months. So that
the moment that the clock starts, they hit the
ground running and they get kind of impact factor
juice out of that publication uh from the start.
And there are various other ways in which the
publishers uh um game, the impact factor and we
all know it's being game but nobody does anything
about it partly because there isn't really anyone to
do anything about it. So um science is not
like the Catholic church, you know, with a guy
at the top who can sort of say as
of tomorrow, this happens. Science is much more like
um uh Sunni Islam, you know, very, very, very
distributed, no hierarchy, no kind of, you know, great
hierarchy of the, of, of the priesthood. I apologize
to any Sunni Muslims watching this. But the impression
I have is that Sunni in particular is extremely
decentralized. And so there isn't even anybody who could
decide to do this. And when you see people
on Twitter saying, well, we should do this. It's
like, well, you can't because the, you know, the
only people who could decide to do that are
the publishers and they will decide what's in the
interests of their shareholders by and large. Those that
are run for profit. And the funny, the, the
kind of tragic thing is even publishers that aren't
run for profit tend to behave as if they
are. So, for example, the American Psychological Association is,
is really one of the worst offenders in many
publishing practices, even though in theory, it only works
for the benefit of its members.
But, but I mean, uh uh related to that,
how is it? I want to ask you this
question because I mean, particularly for people who are
not associated with academia or have academia related occupations,
perhaps, sometimes it might feel very hard to understand
how this happens. But how is it that so
much bad science sometimes go unchecked for so long
because, well, first of all, so much gets published,
I mean, we, we publish 234 orders of magnitude
more science than we can consume as, as scientists.
Um, YOU have a, if you work in a
department, you work in the psychology department at a
large university and you're coming in the morning and
read your calling. Oh, my paper got accepted. Oh,
they'll say congratulations. They won't read it, they haven't
got time. So there's this absolute fire hose of
publications coming at us and almost nobody will ever
read any of them. Um, SO that's the, the,
we, we're just publishing way too much. So, nobody
who's likely to have a, a particularly critical opinion
is likely to read your paper. Now, if you're
in a very small area then maybe they will.
And if it's a, you know, small but, uh,
important area, but then you're gonna read that through
the lens probably of your professional jealousies of the
author anyway. So that's another. But by and large,
it's because we publish too much, we just publish
way, way, way too much. And so, OK, there's
this paper, it says that this modulates the imp
implement of this on this. Oh, ok. If I'm
working in that I might find it. But it's
quite often you won't find that you won't cite
that paper because you remember reading it, you'll cite
that paper cos you'll be looking for some support
for your argument in your literature review and you'll
Google it and you'll read the abstract. But one
of the things that happens certainly happens a lot
with my papers is when I read papers that
cite what I've written in a, a third or
more of the cases. They actually think it says
the opposite of what I said, cos they haven't
read or understood it. They've just kind of, you
know, oh, we sh we should, we should cite
something to say. X and say, yeah, I think
that Nick Brown guy had a paper that did
it and they'll go to Google Scholar and they'll
look at the titles and they'll click on something
and they'll read the abstract and go, yeah. Good
enough Brown and whatever. 2015. And they're either citing
the wrong paper or they haven't read, you know,
they haven't read it or they've missed the word
not out or something. And, and, and so it's,
it's just being produced in French. We say a
la loche by the bucket load, by the bucket
load. And when you produce stuff by the bucket
load, that's what happens. You know, you can't produce
masterpieces uh on a, on a production line. So
really, it starts with the fact that we're producing
way too much science. But what happened was 1945
we'd won World War Two or the Americans, you
know, we won World War two with science. Science
is good. Therefore more science is better. And um,
you know, even today, it's quite hard for even
the most kind of pro maga people to suggest
cutting the science budget. Uh But if you know,
if, if, if uh next year you get President
Trump and he decides to cut the science budget
by 90% I'm gonna be hard pushed, I'm gonna
be hard pushed to tell you why he shouldn't
because I think we have 1020 times too many
people doing science to be able to do anything
useful. We've got enormous numbers of people doing kind
of science. Busy work. I don't know if you
know the term busy work. It's, it's, it's w
when you're a kindergarten teacher it's what you do
to keep the kids quiet and do some cutting
out, do some painting, you know, fill up some
time. Um, AND we, we've got people doing enormous
amounts of science, busy work. They're not going to
discover anything. They're not using methods that are going
to discover anything. We're sort of claiming that we're
training them to be scientists, but they're not, you
know, they're not making any worthwhile discoveries and they're
not going to make any worthwhile discoveries. And it's,
again, it's not a nice thing to say to
people. I, I do sometimes have this discussion with
my fellow scientists and to my, they don't push
back as much as I, as much as I
uh expect when I say, I think we need
to get rid of 90% of scientists. Um Most
of them seem to think they'll be in the
remaining 10%. Uh MAYBE I have very talented uh
friends. But uh it, it, we are just doing
way, way, way too much. We're doing way too
much science and as a result, there's lots of
garbage. Now, if we got rid of the problem
is if we got rid of 90% we probably
wouldn't get rid of the right 90% because, you
know, when you, when you, when you do that
kind of exercise people survive on the basis of
favoritism and friendships. And, um, but yeah, I think
we do have to give some thought to doing
less science heretical though. That is
a a and, but realistically speaking, what would you
say could be some solutions here, particularly when it
comes to publishing, to really try to avoid as
much as possible. Uh Bad science getting published. Well,
to start with. Absolutely, every paper should present the
full raw data and the every computational step that
was done to get to the results and people
sort of go oh, but what about human subjects
protection and in 99% of cases in psychology, that's
just an excuse. Um You know, absolute you, yes,
if you're doing research among politic, you know, political
dissidents in some country and their lives are in
danger or if you're dealing with highly vulnerable people,
then maybe, then maybe, then we can talk about
it, then we can have specialized journals. But the
default ought to be, you show your raw data
as a minimum to the reviewers. There may be
data that you can't publish. But the idea that
you have data that is so sensitive that only
you are allowed to see it and not your
peers who are reviewing it is like, well, what
qualifications did you go through to make you able
to see those sensitive data. Why are you allowed
to know the names of these political dissidents are
not your peers who promised to keep it quiet?
The medical profession manages this. When I go for
an X ray, you know, and the, my doctor
wants a second opinion. He sends it through. He
doesn't go. Oh, yeah. No, I'm not gonna send
it through because that other doctor might put your,
you know, might put your genitals on the internet
or something. You know, there are punishments for that.
So we, I if I join, if I might
be your peer reviewer and you won't let you
see the data, but you're hiring and if I
join your lab tomorrow, hey, I could, I could
just open the file. So, you know, it's not
like this is nuclear secrets. This is simply a
question of covering your arse a bit. Yes. Some
stuff is sensitive but you can get away with,
oh, it's sensitive and everyone has to go. Oh,
it's sensitive. OK. Right. And nobody goes, no, it
isn't. No, that's just bullshit because we don't like
going to people who are telling bullshit stories and
say sorry. That's bullshit in the same way when
people say, oh yeah, I sorry, I don't have
the data. I accidentally wiped the hard drive with
the only copy of the data on it. Well,
that isn't true. Nobody accidentally wipes a hard drive
and nobody who is capable of wiping a hard
drive is not also fully aware that they need
to make backups. So, what do you do when
somebody makes a claim that is completely unreasonable and
everyone's laughing at them behind their back, but nobody
actually stands up and go, mate. Seriously. No, no,
that's bullshit. We go. All right. Yes, we have
to respect professors on this. No. Sorry. The guy
is being massively disingenuous. He probably has something to
hide. Let's, uh, look further. But we don't do
that because it's, it's still at that level. A
gentleman's club. Um, SCIENCE is very much a gentleman's
club because academia works that way. Um, YOU know,
how do you get a university to investigate a
senior professor when they, you know, they're godfather to
each other's kids or something? Um, YOU know, it's,
it's very difficult. There's a reason why, for example,
um, law enforcement people tend not to have many
friends outside law enforcement and vice versa because if
you have a good friend who is a, you
know, senior detective, he knows that there's a chance
one day he may have to bust you. Yeah.
Um, YOU know, the police know how many people
there are out there committing offenses of various kinds
and it's an enormous number. Uh, I, I saw
a thing, I wish I had a source for
this about 25 years ago and it was one,
it was 10 million people in the UK. So
population 60,000,010 million people have a conviction for a
conviction for something that isn't a motoring offense. And
if you assume most of those are men, that's
about one men in three. So that one man
in three has been convicted in a court of
law now, probably something minor, probably just drunk and
disorderly or, you know, urinating in a public place
or whatever it is. Nonetheless, one man in three
in the UK. And I don't see any obvious
reason why it should be vastly less elsewhere has
some kind of. And so, you know, when you're
in law enforcement, you know that there's, there's a,
there's a chance, what am I going to do
one day if I have suspicions that Ricardo is
committing fraud. Uh And so law enforcement tends to
be done separately from the rest of society and
these people tend to exist. It's one reason why
people don't always trust police officers cos we don't
really know them, we don't get to know them.
So come back to academia all of a sudden,
Professor X is accused of something and there's a
committee consisting of professors A B and C to
investigate them. It's, it's very awkward for everybody, very
awkward for everybody. So the there is no real
method by which that can be investigated because there's
no police, there's no prosecutors and the, the bad
people know that they, when if somebody says Blimey,
how did you get that amazing result? You know,
you're not gonna go, I made the data up.
You're gonna come up with some moderately bullshit excuse.
But your colleague who you've had coffee with every
morning for the last five years is not gonna
go, Nick. That's just bullshit. What's wrong with you?
Because we don't do that with our colleagues. We
just don't, I'm sure you've come across situations in
journalism where people have just made up stories. Mhm.
You know, how do you deal with that when
you suspect that this interview? Oh, wow, great interview
with the, with the defense minister. Wasn't, wasn't he,
wasn't he in Australia at the time? Um Should
I ask about that? I'll, I'll, I'll just keep
quiet, I'll wait for more evidence. Um And, and
we as, as a society and a society of
polite middle class, educated individuals are not very good
at calling out situations where we go, hold on
is, is, is this just all lies cos it's
not something we, it's not something we're used to
dealing with. And, and so as a result, the
bad faith people can get away with a lot
because they just exploit the fact that nobody's ever
gonna ask them. And in many cases, these are
people who have been doing this since they were
Children and they quickly learned as a child that
if you develop the right kind of um obfuscated
uh sta um strategies to deflect attention uh that,
that will work. And I'm sure you know, you
knew people like this and, you know, people like
this in your life who've gone through their lives,
they're not quite what they seem but they're pretty
good at hiding it and you get them in
every walk of life and you get science.
But, uh, I, I mean, let me ask you
then a different kind of question. So do you
think that as individual readers of the scientific literature,
I mean, as people that are interested in science,
that we can really do much to avoid, at
least sometimes giving rhythm to some bad science. I
mean, because we went through some examples here today
and at least in one of them, you mentioned
how hard it was to go through the data
and the statistical analysis and all of that. I
mean, it shouldn't we expect that uh most people
or even all of us at least now and
then uh will give grievance to some bad science
and
intentionally. Yeah. No, you, you can't, you can't uh
to a first approximation, you can't. Um And if
that results in staring into the abyss, then welcome
to the abyss. Uh YOU can't, you have to
trust something at some point. Uh OTHERWISE you end
up being a total conspiracy crank. Um And so
um yeah, it, it, it gets, it, it gets
pretty dark, it gets pretty dark in places because
it's like, well, why should I trust this vaccine?
You know, why should I believe that climate change
is real and you know, I, I trust vaccines
and I believe climate change is real, but um
science is not doing itself any favors by tolerating
this kind of behavior. So, I mean, one of
the things I was involved in, in, from about
two years ago, uh was somebody who was faking
climate related research. Um She was making out that
the effect of dissolved carbon dioxide increase in dissolved
carbon dioxide, increased ocean acidification, which is a well
known phenomenon. Uh And she was making out that
the effect it was having on fish was absolutely
catastrophic and she was making all of her data
up now, that doesn't mean that the effect might
not be catastrophic, but it hands ammunition on a
plate to people who say, who go, who say
climate change is a scam. It's all being done
by researchers for grant money because in this case,
it was now, uh that's kind of embarrassing. I
don't think she was typical and, and, and she
wasn't doing research into the actual kind of climate
science. It was the, you know, the knock on
effect, but it's true that in, um, it's certainly
true that in, in most fields of, of animal
biology, for example, uh it's a lot easier to
get your research funded if you can chick tick
the climate change box. Yeah. So, uh you know,
we're, we're not doing ourselves any favors uh by
insisting on you know, everything has to be tied
to that. But I, I, yeah, this and then
this person came from a lab which produces a
whole load of dubious research. And I think, I
don't know whether people go in there as honest
citizens and come out believing that they're making discoveries
by fabricating the data. Maybe they get on such
a kind of mission on what is an extremely
important topic that they think it's OK to fake
results. Certainly the people who blew the whistle uh
on this individual are, you know, mainstream, mainstream biologists
concerned about the impact of climate change. But they
also say it's not doing anyone any favors to
exaggerate the the impact um or to to fake
data about it. So in terms of trust in
science, yeah, for exa another example is III I
worked with some people on various fake COVID cures
and those are relatively easy to debunk because most
of the studies claiming, you know, most of the
trials claimed to have been done never took place
and the data were fake. But the same per
one of the people who was I was helping
with that has discovered that pfizer still hasn't released
one of their uh chunks of trial data that
they should have done. You know, I had my
Pfizer jab yesterday, I have reasonable faith. You know,
I had COVID, I didn't get as ill as
I probably could have done if I hadn't had
the jab, but they still haven't released those data.
Come on, come on, you know, um you know,
uh so there, you know, there is bad behavior
at all the levels, I suppose after a while,
it just becomes a question of the overwhelming consensus.
Um AND particularly in reproducible sciences, then you kind
of look at the consensus. So if someone produces
a bad uh a bad paper on, on superconductors,
for example, there's always something about superconductors. Um YOU'LL
know within three months, if it's real cos somebody
will go and try and make the same, you
know, compound and it'll either work or it won't
and that will get dropped very quickly in psychology
because the concepts are all so kind of malleable.
Uh You can always plead that they weren't really
testing what you thought, what they thought they were
testing and you can eventually the line of research
will collapse. But by then you'll have retired, you'll
have got the best selling book, 15 years will
have gone by and nobody will care. So it's,
it's much easier to um to get away with
that kind of thing in, in a, in psychology.
And then in, in, in basic biology research, the
problem is that there's so many diseases and so
many genes that anyone, a lot of these fake
papers that are written to order you just pick
a gene, pick a disease and someone will write
a story saying the two are linked with experiments
that never took place, but it's very formulaic and
no one will ever test that because the chances
are that nobody's looking at that gene for that
disease every so often somebody might come along and
say, oh, I was interested, oh, and, and I
got misled by this fake paper. But the, these
fake papers mostly are just bulking out the journals
and bulking up the university's kind of count of
how much prestigious research we're doing. But there isn't
even a great danger of them causing too much
individually causing too much problem because nobody's even gonna
read them. Yeah. And, and, and you get this
rather kind of ca care situation of, of, um,
I call them, write only papers, you know, they,
they, they're only ever written and published and nobody
ever reads them but somebody somewhere has an economic
interest in doing that. I don't know if you
ever Google, sometimes you Google for a phrase and
there's this page on the internet of complete gibberish
that's been copied and pasted from 25 different and
maybe translated into Albanian and back to English. And
you go, what even is this page doing? And
there aren't any adverts on there but there's somebody
somewhere has identified that there's a very small economic
benefit to doing that. And, and uh yeah, it,
it, it, it's like that a lot of, a
lot of what's called scientific publication is just very,
very marginal economic benefits. From somebody and that appears
to have no impact on anyone else. You know,
who is the victim, who is the victim. If
I publish a scientific paper about research that never
took place on a gene disease link that no
one else is interested in investigating who's the, who's
the victim? Yeah, it's, it's difficult. It, how would
you ever prosecute that on what basis would you
try to discipline somebody? And if you only discover
it three years later and they've moved on to
another university, the university where they were at the
time says, well, they left the university where they
are now, will say, hey, it wasn't done at
our university and, and um a lot of fraudulent
people, if you, if you move every three years,
you'll, you, you'll essentially never get formally sanctioned for
any form of malpractice because your current university will
never investigate you for stuff at another place. And
your previous place says, hey, they moved on. That's,
uh you know, if you imagine, imagine if you
could commit actual kind of financial fraud by moving
on to a different bank every three years.
Well, but uh I mean, related to that when
it comes to the idea that we communicate to
people, and I, I still think it's a good
idea of course, when we tell people that they
should trust the experts. Uh AND, and I mean,
we really do need to trust the experts because
realistically speaking, we cannot evaluate data from all sorts
of places by ourselves. I mean, that's impossible. But
uh but, but since there's still some bad science,
some fraudulent science, I mean, sometimes I'm afraid that
if we just say without adding anything to it
without adding any warnings or nuance with uh trustee
experts, then if sometimes it happens that people know
that all this piece of science, this piece of
research got published and then five years later, it
was discovered that it was just pure fraud or
something like that, that people might get cynical and
think, oh, ok, if it works like that, then
uh I will just go like this. If it
confirms my pre-existing beliefs, then I will trust the
experts if it doesn't to hell with it. So,
you know, so how should we handle it?
Well, I I there's not much you can do
about what people, what people out there want to
believe. Uh I think the, the issue is when
it starts affecting public policy. Um AND, and we,
you know, you, when you, when you see the
kind of Q and on crazies, uh finding themselves
actually getting elected to congress, et cetera. Um And
you know, there are one or two an rabidly
anti vax members of parliament in the UK. Um
But um by and large, I think you have
to sort of hope for the wisdom of the,
of the majority. I think also the majority of
scientific fraud. Is in areas that people don't really
care about. Uh It's not taking place in, in
uh the most basic stuff that can be replicated
easily and which turns into technology, whether that's medical
technology, uh or, um, or, or computer technology that
said, I think there is a, we are approaching
a point where, for example, a lot of drug
development is now on drugs that have moderate effects
at best and whether or not those effects are
real and how will we discover if they're not?
Um, SO, you know, nobody's going to doubt the
effect of penicillin, for example, but if you have
a new disea, uh if you have a new
drug for, I mean, talk about Alzheimer's, which is
in the news at the moment with two or
three stories of, of various forms of either historical
or current fraudulent research. How do you know that
an Alzheimer's drug is working? And how do you
know that it's working when it claims when the
only claim their claim is not, you know, Alzheimer's
will go away, you know, your, your, your grandmother
is going to be, you know, playing chess at
national level in three years time. Um When the
claim is that it makes significant difference to the
severity of symptoms. Uh, HOW are you going to
test that? Because these things are all based on
samples and averages and there's always gonna be people
for whom it doesn't work. We've got used to
having medicines that have relatively dramatic effects. You know,
we bring in a measles vaccine and all of
a sudden the number of measles cases goes from
that down to here. I mean, you can, um,
it's, it's quite easy to hide poor science if
your claim is fairly modest. Now, normally, when claims
are fairly modest, they don't then become that important.
So obvious you get things in psychology and, you
know, we're going to reduce your back depression inventory
score from 4.2 and 3.8. But people aren't rushing
out to change public policy on that basis. You
know, maybe one or two people are going to
an expensive training course they didn't need. But if
you come along and say we, you know, we're
going to reduce Alzheimer's symptoms, we're going to delay
the onset of dependency by 18 months on average.
And people are reading about this, this new drug
and you're going well, my mum, my dad is
an early stage Alzheimer's if we could have 18
months more with them before, you know, these things
are fairly inevitable. But before the decline, how much
would you pay for that? Or how much would
you in a European context? You know, demand that
your health system pays for that rather than shingles
vaccine. I have to go for a shingles vaccine
tomorrow and it's expensive. Um And how would we
know if it was or wasn't having an effect?
And it's really quite difficult because, you know, we
do that on the basis of observation report of
the statistics and those kind of, that kind of
research is quite, is quite easy to falsify. So
I think that is historically, it's not been too
much of a problem because the kind of gee
whiz claims that have turned out to be false,
the kind of Cyril Burt, uh, things, the, I
think psychology stuff, um, has tended to be fairly
fluffy stuff. But with one or two exceptions, uh
with things like the nudging and the, you know,
signing the paper at the top to say you'll
be honest, one or two, but it hasn't really
had a huge impact. But the, the medical stuff
I'm starting to worry about now because the claims
are no longer, you take one of these pills,
it costs $3 and, and, you know, it will
go away. We will know we, we, the, I,
they're talking now about malaria vaccines that are 50
or 60% efficient and can be made for, I
don't know, 20 $30. If we deploy several, tens
of millions of those, we will see, we will
see in the figures that there is that much
less malaria and we will know that they work
um, some of these other drugs that, you know,
with modest claim effects, how are we gonna know
if they're working or not? It, it's very difficult
because the, you know, the whole initial claim is
difficult to evaluate uh uh uh a percentage drop
of this, you know, with what statistical techniques. And
even if the research is being done, honestly, people
don't always agree about the right way to analyze
these things. So yeah, historically, it was I think
simpler because you make, you know, you claim you
made a superconductor, nobody needs to worry about that
because in three months time, we'll either know if
it works or if it doesn't. Uh But if
you play some of the, some of the stuff
in, in the medical area is, is and we
know we know that plenty of drugs are marketed
that don't work. Mhm. Uh And, and sometimes are
worse than useless. Um And then was that because
of statistical errors in the phase three trials or
was there faking going on? Um Yeah, difficult or,
or
sometimes you even get unregulated stuff like supplements, for
example.
Uh Yes, but at least no one's, I mean,
no one's hopefully taking some of the those claims
seriously. But I was talking this morning, this is
someone on Twitter about there's this drug that makes
you apparently lose weight quite effectively. I forgot its
name. I think we V is one of the
brand names. And so what's happening now is people
are buying a fake version of it over the
internet because everyone read about it. Let's assume the
research is genuine and that the, the drug is
great. The pro the problem is the drug's quite
hard to get, you have to get it prescribed
and your doctor won't necessarily prescribe it for, you
know, something minor. Uh, AND so people are going
out to the internet and buying it or at
least they think they're buying it. They're probably just
getting, you know, flour and water or something. Uh,
BUT to some extent that's a problem. It, you've
got a, you've got a societal problem caused by
the research on this drug that arguably kind of
isn't the fault of the people who made the
drug. But the, the press got hold of it.
You've got to get this, you know, and, and
they get whatever the 10 letter name of the
drug is, you've gotta get this and people go
and type it into Google and off, they go.
Um, THAT'S another problem for society of, of, um,
sort of criminal derivation of, of, of, of, of,
of scientific research that we also have to look
at. So I think there's an even wider problem
of, of how do you communicate truth to people,
um, whether it's scientific truth or, you know, political
truth or, you know, and, and then, you know,
so we, we t, I don't know it, this
is the kind of thing that we ought to
be able to ask psychologists about. It's just that
psychologists aren't very good at it as we've seen.
Um, IF you look at, you know, during COVID,
um, some of the advice from the psychologist. Well,
it was based on this kind of crappy nudging
theory. Most of which I think is probably, is
probably at least at the very least bad, bad
signs and quite a lot of it I suspect
is faked. Um, BUT, oh, yes, the nudging. Yes.
Um, THERE was a book you could buy at
the airport called Nudge.
You remember that one?
Well, for example, that book, the first edition was
full of uh cute stuff by Brian Wansink, the
food research guy who then got fired by Cornell
after we showed that he'd been uh well, amongst
other things, making up his data. And uh and
then the second edition of that book came out,
but they just dropped all those references. They didn't
put a Ford say, oops, the first edition of
this book was full of bullshit about that. Well,
that all turned out to be crap. But this
stuff, you know, trust us all the rest's really
solid. They didn't say anything at all. They just
produced a new edition and he was airbrushed out.
Um You know, and they, you know, these gu
the um these guys make quite a lot of
money selling those books and it was a bit
embarrassing. So, uh it's, it, it's a genuine problem,
but the problem is there isn't anyone who can
do anything about it. There isn't a pope, there
isn't a pope to say guys the entire scientific
community, you're stop doing this or there will be
consequences. Um So all we can, I think all
we can do is have um people like yourself
holding science to account uh and asking those awkward
questions and um you know, talking to people who
disagree with me as well, but we, we have
to have that level of scrutiny. Nothing would have
happened in the Weinstein case, for example, if Buzzfeed
hadn't, uh hadn't gone on to it, uh, because
it became too embarrassing for Cornell not to do
anything about it. Uh
And uh, I mean, actually the nudge book, uh
reminded me of, uh Dan Arielle who I guess
I, I, if I, if I'm not mistaken, even
rec just recently published a new book and iii
I haven't even read the book. But after all
the, the things that uh uh came out since
2021 about these fraudulent data and all of that,
I would imagine that probably he's still promoting some
of his fake ideas as if
they were, but it's his business model. He can't,
you know, he can't back away from that. He's
committed to that view of the world in which
uh very small subtle interventions that only he knows
about, um, you know, make a difference. And it's,
it's, it, you know, no, nobody else reproduces these
things. There's this whole thing of mindset theory. So
the mindset theory is that, you know, students with
a growth mindset, you know, achieve better. And it's
strange because this, the claim is that any teacher,
any school teacher can go into their class and
apply this. But no psychologists have ever been able
to replicate it. So apparently it can be replicated
freely by the person who invented it, any school
teacher, but no other psychologists. Um, AND, yeah, that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to me.
Um, AND the, um, the, the naive reader would
draw conclusions about that which, um, scientists are too
polite, uh, to draw. But, uh, the, the people
reading the books aren't getting that they say, oh,
you know, I, there, there's this interesting research, my,
my colleagues and I, at university or whatever tested
this with 300 undergraduates. We found that when we
did this, they did that come by us. But,
um, you know, did it happen? Is that what
really happened? Did they know what, you know, does
that, can, we, can we really draw that conclusion?
Probably not. But I've got a book to sell.
Um, AND the, yeah, the nudge type stuff. Freakonomics.
Freakonomics is another one. THE, a lot of the,
what, what they write about, uh, is, is studies
that either never happened or certainly didn't happen as
was described. Um, BUT that, again, that's that whole
industry now, you know, there's that book, think like
a freak and it's like, oh, the thing to
do is to be counterintuitive. Everything is counterintuitive and
when the problem is when you get into everything
being counterintuitive, well, then you're into Chem Trails and
five G and, and all that because, hey, that's
counterintuitive too. Um, AND you know why not? Who
says that can't be possible? Um, IT, it's very
dangerous, it's very dangerous. This idea that absolutely everything
is counterintuitive cos actually most things are, you know,
true on their face. Mhm.
Uh So uh ju ju just to, to wrap
up our conversation, let me just ask you, I
guess one last question. So when it comes to
lay people specifically, if they are exposed to a
paper or to a piece of news on mainstream
media about some new a breakthrough research, something like
that. I mean, do you think that there are
perhaps, or there would be good enough rules of
um even from uh for non experts to follow
where perhaps there would be some things they should
be wary of things, they should pay specific attention
to where if they see them, they should go.
OK. So this is, I should be careful about
this. This is sort of a preposterous claim. Let
me just take a step back and perhaps wait
a while to see if there are some reviews
and critiques that come out to see how it
turns out uh what experts actually we see about
it. Um I'll give a plug here for my
friend Stuart Richie's book called Science Fictions in which
he sort of, in which he, you know, tells,
gives you these steps to go through. But, uh,
I'm not very optimistic that, that many people will
want to do it because people are, people are
absorbing this on their commute into work. You know,
in the, in the, in the, in the 20
minutes free newspaper, a new study shows, blah, blah,
blah. Next page, somebody got mugged in your neighborhood
last night. Next page, the football results. And it's
just part of the, it's just part of the
entertainment churn. And then, yeah, sometimes I'll be out,
I'll meet people on a walk or something and
they'll say, oh, I read that X, you know,
causes why. And it's like, hm. But sometimes people
will say, I don't believe any of it because
they're always telling you that this causes cancer and
then they're telling you that this cures cancer. Why
won't the scientists make up their minds? And I
used to say, I used to say this isn't
the scientists, this is the journalists. Uh, BUT it
turns out that a lot of it is the
scientists and I wish the scientists would stop doing
this. But the scientists will then say, oh yeah,
but we didn't say that, you know, we had
this study and which said that this is associated
with this in rats. Uh But they allowed their,
they allowed their study in rats to be turned
into a news item. Um, AND they might even
say, oh, well, the university press office obliged us
to it. It's like, well, you're not, not obliged
to, you're not obliged. So you can choose not
to do it. You went along with it because
it was the easy thing to do. And then
they might say, yeah, but, you know, my university
ranks people on their public impact and they may
well be right. And so on the other hand,
it is quite difficult to critique people for their
uh behavior as scientists. It, it it's easy to
critique them when they got a million dollar book
deal off the back of it. Understandable why they
would do that. But it's easy to critique them.
It's less easy to critique them when they have
a precarious contract of employment. And they sincerely believe
that going along with a little bit of the
excess of the press department is the requirement to
still have a job paying them 2000 a month
or 4000 a month next year. And I think
we have to be a little bit careful about
dismissing sort of, you know, the, the incentives because
we see the results of the, you know, the
high end thing and the $100,000 consulting gigs. But
we also have to acknowledge that there are lots
and lots of people who really want to keep
doing this line of work um and who are
prepared to do what it takes to stay in
that. It's one of the reasons why I think
we need to have fewer scientists, uh is because
once people are in that system, the system owes
them an honest opportunity to keep going within that.
I think if you have any kind of uh
profession that isn't casual employment and you ask people
to make a commitment to being trained to do
that profession of engineer or, or lawyer or accountant.
I think it's incumbent on that profession, that domain
of human activity to have a reasonable opportunity for
people who've made that commitment to go for a
decent length of career within that field where they
chose to give up their twenties, getting trained. And
at the moment, we have a situation where we,
we train all these scientists but there simply isn't
enough stable employment for them. And as a result,
we make them jump through hoops and, you know,
perform little tricks to stay, um, in, uh which,
which first of all means we select for the
people who are best at doing the little tricks,
but also the whole premise was, well, we'll push
all these phd s through the system and we'll,
we'll cream off the 15 or 20% best ones.
You shouldn't be doing that. You should be selecting
people much more rigorously for their potential to be,
have a good long career as scientists. And I'm,
I if you go along to law school and
you're just not up to, you know, whatever I
don't know what the qualifications are or what. But
I'm sure there are ways, I'm sure there are
people who go to law school and after two
months, you know, people around them will realize, look
sorry, but you're never gonna make it in the
law, you know, because of the way your mind
works or whatever it is. And, you know, hopefully,
well, you failed them perhaps. I don't know. Uh,
BUT we, we, we, it seems to me that
in science that is completely out of whack and
we're bringing in so many people and then they,
they, they wanna continue in what they're doing. But
that's, I think a legitimate social contract with people
now who is running that system. I don't know.
But worlds of, I don't know, don't know about
journalism but words of engineering law and things like
that when we bring you into the system, the
deal is that if you pass the exams with
a reasonable degree of competency, there will very likely
be a job for you somewhere. And that simply
isn't the case in science. Um And so I,
as I say, my, my fundamental that everything I've
told you in the last two hours, you could
have heard from a dozen other people apart from
perhaps my position that we need to train vastly
fewer scientists than we currently do. Not because the
world might not be a better place with all
those scientists, but because we simply don't have room
for them. We don't have the capacity to absorb
either the people or anything they might output. Uh,
AND we just have to accept that in the
same way that we don't put, um, 20,000 kids
a year through professional football academies. Mhm. You know,
your, uh, whatever your favorite football team is has
an academy and they know they know that 90%
of the 14 year olds won't make it. 70%
of the 16 year olds won't make it. But
they don't, they could, they could take in three
times as many kids. And occasionally, you know, the
ones who they, let's say at the moment they
take in the ones who score nine out of
10, they could take in all the ones who
currently score eight out of 10. Occasionally, one or
two of those would blossom and become 16 year
olds and go on to become professional. But the
trail they would lead in there and there's a,
the cost of doing it. But there's also, I
think a certain moral obligation within that field to
say, look, the chances that he or that this
person will make it as, as a profession are
so low that we're going to take the risk
of missing out on the next Lionel Messi because,
you know, we just have to do that. And
it's, I at the moment it's as if it's
as if your local football team had Tween took
2030 times more people than they need into the
academy. 14 year olds go, hey, I'm at the
FC, whatever academy. That's fantastic. And, and you go,
yeah, you're not gonna, you do know it's very
unlikely. And I think we would, if that was
happening we would consider that there was an ethical,
an ethical problem. Maybe there already is. Maybe they're
already training to me. I don't know. But we
would, you know, we would be talking about that
and I, I don't think we talk about that
in, in science. I'm not certain why or outside
science, maybe that's your next kind of investigative mission
is why are we, why do we train so
many scientists? Because we have so many professors because
they were trained as scientists. You know, we've got
this, we've got this huge machine and it has
to be kept going and we, in our society,
we associate any machine getting smaller as a sign
of failure, right? You know, why have half the
psychology departments in our universities closed? There's not going
to be an article saying actually this is a
good thing, you know, it's going to be interviews
with the people who lost their jobs and, and
my, my kind of assertion is that we shouldn't
have hired a lot of those people in the
first place. But this will, this will, this, this
doesn't make me too popular. I'm surprised that it
doesn't make me more unpopular, but it doesn't. Yeah.
No, no one's no-one's yet invited me on their
podcast to give a good, full 45 minute exposition
of exactly how I think that should work.
Well, I, it's food for thought. Anyway, I guess
let's end on that note. And Doctor Brown, uh,
just before we go, would you like to tell
people where they can find you when you work
on the internet?
So, I'm still on Twitter and, uh, you can
put the link in cos if I try and
spell it, it'll you um you can put my
Twitter handle on there. I, I suppose at some
point I will move over to blue sky like
everybody else. Um And one or other of those
uh will be the best place to contact me.
And if not, um Ricardo, you can put, for
example, the address of my blog um in the
in the blurb and um people will be able
to find my contact details through that.
OK? So I'm leaving links to that in the
description box of the interview and Doctor Brown, thank
you again for taking the time to come on
the show. It's been fun to talk to you,
but I, I enjoyed it and I, I hope
there's uh I hope there's something here you can
use without your lawyers getting to uh getting too
upset.
Hi guys. Thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it.
Leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by N Lights learning
and development. Then differently check the website at N
lights.com and also please consider supporting the show on
Patreon or paypal. I would also like to give
a huge thank you to my main patrons and
paypal supporters, Perera Larson, Jerry Muller and Frederick Suno
Bernard Seche O of Alex Adam, Castle Matthew Whitting
B no Wolf, Tim Ho Erica LJ Connors, Philip
Forrest Connelly. Then the Met Robert Wine in NAI
Z Mark Nevs called in Holbrook Field Governor Mikel
Stormer Samuel Andre Francis for Agns Ferger, Ken Herz
J and La Jung Y and the K Hes
Mark Smith J. Tom Hummel Sran David Wilson, the
dear Roman Roach Diego, Jan Punter, Romani Charlotte, Bli
Nicole Barba Adam Hunt, Pavlo Stass, Nale Me, Gary
G Alman, Samo, Zal Ari and YPJ Barboza Julian.
Price Edward Hall, Eden Broner Douglas Fry Franka Gilon
Cortez Solis Scott Zachary, Ftw Daniel Friedman, William Buckner,
Paul Giorgino, Luke Loki, Georgio Theophano, Chris Williams and
Peter Wo David Williams Di A Costa Anton Erickson
Charles Murray, Alex Chao Marie Martinez, Coralie Chevalier, Bangalore
Fist Dey Junior, Old Einon Starry Michael Bailey then
Spur by Robert Grassy Zorn, Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul
Barnabas Radick Mark Temple, Thomas Dvor Luke Neeson Chris
to Kimberley Johnson, Benjamin Gilbert Jessica. No, Linda Brendan
Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensley Man George Katis Valentine Steinman
Perros, Kate Van Goler, Alexander Abert Liam Dan Biar
Masoud. Ali Mohammadi Perpendicular Jer Urla. Good enough, Gregory
Hastings David Pins of Sean Nelson, Mike Levin and
Jos Net. A special thanks to my producers is
our web Jim Frank Luca stuffin, Tom. We and
Bernard N Corti Dixon, Bendik Muller Thomas Trumble, Catherine
and Patrick Tobin, John Carlman, Negro, Nick Ortiz and
Nick Golden. And to my executive producers Matthew Lavender,
Si Adrian Bogdan Knits and Rosie. Thank you for
all.